somebody's listening to this podcast
right now and I promise you her number
one challenge is not expanding her world
enough worrying about the Judgment of
people when you walk into new
environments that's every one of our
challenges you know Street kid from
Detroit you should go to the US
Open tennis tournament and get some
different flate like it's it it's the
game because then the other thing is
when you grow up in adversity it's the
foundation of your success you already
know what losing tastes like you're not
scared of it and you're crafty when you
grow up in a jungle you know there's
anim around the corner you grow up in a
zoo you don't